>>Presenter: Welcome everyone to Photographers
at Google. My name is Ricardo Lagos. I’m
a software developer. It’s my distinct pleasure
to introduce you to our special guest, photographer
Eric Cheng. Eric’s award-winning photography
has been published in over 60 magazines and
books worldwide. He has won contests such
as Nature’s Best Magazine’s Photo Competition,
which placed some of his work in the Smithsonian
Natural History Museum.
Eric is the editor and publisher of wetpixel.com,
the premier online community for underwater
photographers. Wetpixel provides a forum for
photographers to share their work and to discuss
ocean-related issues, in turn educating viewers
about the beauty and fragility of the marine
ecosystem. Eric’s work with wetpixel.com
was awarded the prestigious Underwater Imaging
Website of the Year from the Antibes Festival.
Through Wetpixel expeditions, Eric leads regular
photography expeditions and workshops around
the world. He has given seminars and lectures
internationally at events such as TEDx, Boston
Sea Rover’s Clinic, DEMA, Digital Shootouts,
Kona Classic, scuba diving magazine events,
and others.
Eric is also involved in ocean conservation,
and is technical advisor and photographer
for the Sea Shepherds’ Conservation Society.
He was head photographer for the Operation
Musashi, Sea Shepherds’ 2008 and 2009 anti-whaling
campaign in Antarctica, which was featured
in season two of the hit TV show Whale Wars.
You can find more info about Eric and his
photography at echeng.com. Eric, thanks for
taking time to come to Google today, and welcome.
[applause]
>>Eric Cheng: Thanks so much for having me.
That was a very official bio. It’s funny
because Ricardo told me that in the version
that he sent out to Google, he said something
like, “Eric was bumming around for a few
years and took some pictures.” [laughter]
Both are accurate, and I fully own up to both.
Thanks again for having me. I actually started
out as a software engineer. Twelve years ago,
or I guess even longer now, I worked in a
cubicle. I guess cubes are not in anymore.
But I started out in software.
I discovered photography—I had discovered
photography earlier than that, but had not
gone underwater with a camera. So nothing
had ever stuck in the photography realm. It
was really when I took a camera underwater
that it changed my life. It was the inspiration
I needed to move my photography beyond something
technical into something that really felt
like photography. Before, I could take a picture
that was sharp, well-exposed, but it never
did anything for people. It was missing the
inspiration.
It very quickly changed my life. I worked
as a photographer and publisher for about
ten years before coming back into industry.
Now I’m at Lytro. There’s a big Lytro contingent
over here, on the right side.
I want to talk a little bit about—just a
little bit about the gear and technique involved
in photography, but mostly tell stories of--
underwater photography, but mostly tell stories
about specific shots and locations.
This is a quick summary of the housing market
out there for cameras. There’s a huge range.
You can get OEM plastic housings for point-and-shoot
cameras for $150, $180. But in the high ends,
typically, a full rig for SLR aluminum housings,
machined aluminum housings with strobes and
all the support necessary to hold those strobes
with articulating arms runs $12,000+. So it’s
a huge range.
Up there on the—in the middle is a GoPro
housing. These are becoming more and more
popular for underwater video and photography,
although until a few months ago, they didn’t
focus underwater without third party housings.
I have met film crews out in the field who
have discovered that after the shoot, because
their, in fact, topside videographers taking
cameras underwater, thinking it’s very much
the same. But it is not.
What’s happening now, as well, is that these
mirrorless cameras are becoming more and more
popular underwater. Here’s a little line
up of Nauticam housings. The Sony NEX series
is pretty popular. The NEX 7 in particular
is really interesting because you can put
magnified obstacle viewfinders to look at
their very large electronic viewfinder underwater.
This Olympus OMDEM5, easy to remember model
name, is also really popular. People have
been getting great results with them. So things
are changing underwater. Typically, a little
bit behind what happens on land.
This is a very old picture of me in the water.
This is from 2003, with my second SLR rig.
It was a Canon D60. Sea and Sea Housing. But
pretty much the anatomy of an underwater rig
has not changed. You have some kind of housing,
a very large dome port for wide angle, for
the optics that—for clear, sharp wide angle
shots underwater. Some kind of lighting, so
in this case, two Ico Light strobes, and articulating
arms. [pause]
This is a shot that’s a little bit more recent.
Again, the cameras have not changed that much
in the professional underwater photography
world, still photography world. This is a
Seacam housing with a Canon 1DS Mark III.
[pause]
So one thing that is very specific to underwater
photography is that we basically carry around
mobile studios. We’re carrying strobes, articulating
arms, and underwater photography is almost
completely manual. We shoot manual exposure,
manual strobes. The idea is basically to expose
to the background and fill the foreground.
There’s not very much color underwater. Water
strips out light starting from red all the
way down the spectrum. We need to bring full
spectrum lighting down to get these colors
to pop.
This is a picture taken with a setup like
the one you saw on the previous slide. It’s
a very wide angle shot taken in eastern Indonesia,
in Raja Ampat. Those of you who are divers
will recognize Raja Ampat as being the place
where the reefs are the best. It’s an incredible
location. It’s incredibly diverse. In fact,
if you go underwater and count fish for a
fixed amount of time, which is how they measure
diversity, this area has the highest diversity
of any area in the world, underwater. There’s
some theories about why this might be. One
theory is that during the Ice Age, everything
froze over except for this section, and so
the fish survived here and then repopulated
around the world.
Because it’s incredibly remote, most of the
diving in places like this are done by Liveabord
dive vessel. The Liveaboards are usually pretty
nice. This is one that I went on, on the upper
left. The diving’s done by tender.
When I started going here, nobody was there.
There were maybe two boats out there. Now,
it is incredibly popular, and is managed as
a national park. But because it’s very remote,
and there are dozens of Liveaboards operating
there, you still don’t see very many people
when you go.
In addition to really nice reefs, there’s
a lot of marine life here. This is a school
of baitfish over a reef that looks what a
reef looks like if you’re 20 feet away. So
this is what everything looks like underwater
until you light it. This was really cool.
These baitfish were actually being hunted
by jacks. You can see the whole school moving
as one organism. The action is pretty interesting,
but it’s hard to get an interesting picture
from something like this. While it’s interesting
to look at, you have to think about how to
get a shot.
In this little ledge there, or a bunch of
interesting corals, these are really interesting
corals to see under the water. They’re very,
very shallow, and particularly interesting
because they’re in a location where you can
shoot upwards through the surface of the water
and see some trees. So I played around here
and took some shots, but I felt like something
was missing. So I went back to that location
and just waited, and I noticed that those
baitfish were moving around a lot on top of
me. So I just waited. I took a lot of pictures.
Eventually, I got the shot that I wanted,
which was a shot where the baitfish were above
me, but you could see through the school to
see some of the surface elements. So this
is—
>>Male #1: How shallow is it, and is it natural
light?
>>Cheng: How shallow is it, and is it natural
light? It’s very shallow. It’s like ten
feet deep. It is natural light in the background,
but strobe-filled in the foreground. This
is in the shadow of a cliff. So there’s no
light. If you had taken this without, you
would have gotten just silhouette.
So lighting is really interesting underwater
because there are a lot of particles floating
around. If you use a flash that’s very close
to the lens, it lights up all of those particles
between you and your subject. That’s called
“backscatter.” Even though the visibility
was not that great in the shot that I showed
before, you don’t see very much backscatter.
That’s because we light things like this.
This is a picture my friend David Fleetham's
set up. It illustrates how we position strobes.
Where the fall off lighting intersects is
where you want your subject to be. The reason
we do that is so that none of the water between
you and the subject is illuminated, so it
doesn’t ruin your shot.
>>Male #2: In this shot, and in the previous
shots, it wasn’t very obvious: are your cameras
neutrally buoyant?
>>Cheng: Are cameras neutrally buoyant? They
can be made to be neutrally buoyant.
>>Male #2: How about your setup?
>>Cheng: Mine is slightly negative. Historically,
manufacturers have not paid attention to buoyancy,
and they should. Video housing manufacturers
do pay quite a lot of attention to buoyancy.
But if it’s too heavy, it becomes very difficult
to hold, so we will typically put closed cell
foam floats on the setup to make it more buoyant
until it’s where you like it. If it’s totally
neutral, I find that it also becomes difficult
to use for stills.
So again, here’s the shot from before. You
can see the strobes are really never pointing
at the subject. They’re always pointing slightly
out so the fall off light is what brushes
the subject in front of you. It’s a nice
soft light. And, of course, the choice of
strobe matters. Some strobes have a very hard
edge, and it’s hard to use that fall off
lighting to light your subjects.
So again, the goal is really to expose the
background and to fill the foreground. You
get these nice colors popping in the front,
but a nice dark blue in the background. Cameras
do not expose—They’re not designed to expose
well underwater, so if you just take a camera
underwater and just take a picture in auto
mode, you’ll get a very bright background.
Who knows what you’ll get in the foreground.
We just fill-- use these strobes to fill.
If you’re in the shallows, you can shoot
a little bit—You can use white balance. You
don’t need to use strobes as much. You can
use the strobes to fill as much as you can
for these scenes that have subjects that go
further off. But the strobes that we’re bringing
are actually quite big, but they still don’t
light the reef up for very far. They like
maybe six feet in front of you. We shoot super
wide. A lot of fisheye.
These reefs are from Raja Ampat, that same
area. This is one of my favorite shots. It’s
a giant clam in the foreground, reef in the
background. This school of juvenile convict
fish swimming around. What’s interesting
is I had gone there the day before, and the
reef had been dead. Same dive, same location,
different time of day. And when the current
picked up, all the fish came out. It’s a
highly dynamic environment. [pause]
This is a shot of a reef called Mike’s Point
in Raja Ampat. There’s a ton of current flow
through here. These upwellings that feed the
coral. This is what that point looks like
from land. It looks like nothing, really,
but it’s ringed by really incredible reefs.
And, in fact, this little island leaves a
wake because of the current, and was bombed
in World War II because they thought it was
a boat. [laughter] [pause]
Okay. On the other side of the spectrum, we
have very, very small things underwater to
photograph. This is the smallest seahorse
in the world, a pygmy seahorse. That’s one
of my friend’s eyes. So you can see it in
the upper right hand side of the frame. Tiny,
tiny seahorse. Very hard to see. If you’re
over 40, you may never see one in your life.
We have a lot of people who take pictures
where the guide points, and hope it’s in
the frame. That’s not a good way to do it.
[laughter]
That shot was taken in Papua New Guinea. This
is an idea of one of the resorts there. That’s
Lota Wata Island. We used wheelbarrows to
get our gear around. We hopped on a boat,
went to Rabaul, and the volcano blew while
we were there, and covered the reef with ash,
which was very interesting, but not great
for photography.
This is the typical picture people get of
pygmy seahorses. A macroshot. We typically
use 100 millimeter macrolenses. Sometimes
with diopters to get even closer. I took a
bunch of these shots. Didn’t really like
any of them. They’re hard to shoot because
they don’t like you. They don’t like divers.
They don’t’ like light. So if you get really
close to one and try to take a picture, they’ll
turn away and you’ll get shots of them—of
their backs a lot. This picture took a while
to get. I asked a friend to take his mask
of underwater, and just sit in front of—behind
this fan. We waited a long time for the pygmy
seahorse to just continue doing its thing,
until it totally ignored us. Then I was able
to get these shots. So this is that final
shot.
I like this shot a lot because it shows scale.
Typically, you’ll see a full frame shot of
one of these things, and it looks interesting
because it’s a bizarre animal, but you have
no idea how big it is. [pause]
This is another one of my favorites. It’s
unusual. Most people think this is a forest
scene when they see it, but there’s of course
a fish in there. These corals are less than
a foot tall, so the scale is deceiving. The
equipment that was necessary to get this was
a little bit unusual. It’s not used very
often.
This is the camera setup I used for that.
It’s an SLR, a typical SLR rig. But it has
this very long lens in the front, which is
pseudo endoscopic. So it’s a relay lens with
many, many different elements. I think there
are 18 elements or something. Bad for image
quality, but great for composition. And so
what happens is you get a fisheye view, a
very, very wide angle view at the end of the
lens. You can focus all the way up to the
lens. Very unusual underwater. Normally we
use big dome ports for wide angle optics that
prevent you from getting very close to your
subject. Shooting wide angle and macro, close
focus wide angle, is typically very difficult.
We call this the “insect eye lens.” I think
in Japan they call it “bug eye.” So that’s
where that name came from.
This is one of the shots that you can get
with it. If you don’t know what these are,
it might seem like a normal shot. But that
hole in the coral is less than a centimeter
in diameter. And so these are two tiny little
coral hermit crabs shot wide angle from probably
less than a centimeter away. Then you have
the reef falling off in the background. Pretty
unusual shots.
Again, these shots were taken in New Guinea.
But very, very remote New Guinea. These were
taken in a place called the Eastern Fields,
pretty much halfway between Papua New Guinea
and Australia. It’s about 100 miles from
Port Moresby, and there’s a very large sunken
volcano that’s—I think it’s 400 miles in
diameter. But it never breaks the surface,
so treacherous for ships. No boats go there.
There’s only one dive boat I know that goes
here, and one captain who knows it well. So
it’s pristine.
You can see in this picture here. It’s just
shallow reefs when you’re above one. Beautiful
water. These are the corals that I was talking
about. They’re very common corals. These
are the kinds of corals you just swim by,
because they’re so boring. But you can get
a very different view of these corals with
this lens. Specifically, you can insert the
lens under the canopy and get shots from inside
this coral forest, really.
>>Male #1: So the strobes have to go under
the lens?
>>Cheng: So the strobes—The question is about
strobes. The strobe do not go under the lens.
What I’m doing is putting the strobes on
top of the entire—on top of the corals, and
looking for holes I can—from which I can
insert the light.
>>Male #1: So you have them separated? You
don’t have them attached to each other?
>>Cheng: Yeah, the strobes are attached to
the housing by articulating arms, so we can
position them wherever we want. Yeah. [pause]
So here’s the final shot. It looks like this
mossy bank of the left. You can get some other
interesting pictures with this setup. This
is an Emperor shrimp on a rather large nudibranch.
With a normal macrolens, you can’t get the
depth of field necessary to capture this picture.
You get the head and the rhinophores, or you
get the shrimp, or you get the tail. Because
we’re shooting super wide angle here, the
depth of field is quite large.
You can also shoot small animals from their
point of view. These are Coleman shrimp on
a fire urchin. They’re shrimp that live on
a fire urchin. They snip off the spines in
specific areas and live with the protection
of these urchins, which are really nasty if
you touch. These kinds of shots that show
blue in the background and portray these animals
as very lar—as potentially being large are
pretty cool.
These are striped catfish, Plotosus, striped
catfish. Again, shot from their point of view.
They school and feed off of stuff in the sand.
You can just get in front of them and stick
the camera in their face. [pause]
And then again, another very common coral.
This is a mushroom coral, or leather coral,
mushroom leather coral. It’s a really boring
coral. But if you get very close, the polyps
suddenly—the polyps and the shape can be
very interesting. I took this and posted it
around Valentine’s Day, because it looks
kinda like a heart. [pause]
More close-up polyp detail. This is a large
heart coral. Hard to photograph in wide angle
in an interesting way. This shows the alien
landscape.
I have a short video [video starts, water
sounds] of me actually shooting this rig.
You can see how the working distance is really
close. That’s a frogfish, that orange blob.
[video playing] This is a flamboyant cuttlefish.
[video playing] Maybe less interesting than
the frogfish. It just looks like a blob, really.
And these are those Plotosus, striped catfish.
You can see the way they move, this is at
night. And I’m putting a red light on, because
they seem to not like the white light. A lot
of animals don’t respond much to red light,
because there’s not very much red light down
there. [video playing] [video stops playing]
>>Male #3: Was that on a DSLR, or a different
camera?
>>Cheng: It was on a DSLR. I mean, the shots
that I was taking, yeah.
>>Male #3: How about the video?
>>Cheng: Oh, the video. I think they shot
on a camcorder. A friend shot. Yeah, just
camcorder.
Okay, back to wide angle stuff. I think Ricardo
used this picture on one of the events. It’s
a school of scalloped hammerheads taken in
the Galapagos off of Darwin, which is the
northernmost island, which is a place only
divers go to, because you can’t go on land
there. So of course, the Galapagos are very
well known, are very famous for their giant
tortoises, the blue-footed, red-footed boobies,
the northernmost penguins, and marine iguanas.
Albatross, some other stuff too. But underwater,
it is a fantastic place.
It’s really for advanced divers. The currents
are—can be pretty interesting there. You
can see bubbles going sideways on that picture
on the upper left. These bubbles on the right
are bubbles that we exhaled, that are now
below us. So there are lots of down currents
and weird whirlpool-type things. If you’re
not comfortable in the blue, you shouldn’t
go. [laughs] But it’s a really great place.
I have been there one or two times a year
for many years before I got this picture of
the hammerheads. They don’t like bubbles.
They don’t like people or bubbles, so typically,
when you get close to them, they just swim
away from you very quickly. So everything--
all the conditions lined up one year. In fact,
this picture in the lower left was taken right
before I got that shot of the school of hammerheads.
Basically, there’s a very, very strong current,
but there were large boulders we could hide
behind, so we didn’t have to fight. But the
currents would sweep our bubbles away horizontally
away from the hammerheads. And so this large
school of hammerheads—It was also just two
of us. A large school of hammerheads swam
right above us, and the bubbles were swept
away without disturbing them. So I got this
series of shots. You do have to hold your
breath for these shots, which they tell you
never to do underwater.
>>Male #1: So the rebreather is not an option?
>>Cheng: Rebreathers? Rebreathers are an option.
I have never taken them to Galapagos.
>>Male #1: Have you ever taken ?
>>Cheng: Oh. Shops for re-. Yeah. I would
not trust another rebreather. Yeah. Bring
your own rebreather. The problem with rebreathers
is they’re deadly when there are accidents.
[laughs]
And so this shot on the lower right is actually
the scatter shot. At the moment the hammerheads
decided they had enough of me, they scattered.
You can see them going every direction.
Most of the scalloped hammerheads here in
the schools are female. They actually joust
for position within the school. And they’re--
One of the reasons they’re there is to be
cleaned by other fish.
Incidentally, it’s very hard to find hammerheads
now. If you go virtually to any dive site
in the world, there’s always a hammerhead
point with no hammerheads. The reason is that
they are pretty much—Most sharks have been
fished out of the ocean for their fins. And
so one thing that I fight against a lot is
shark finning for the purpose of putting it
in shark fin soup. If you’re interested in
sharks, please contact me.
This is really one of the last places on the
planet where you can see large schools of
hammerhead sharks, another being Cocos Island
and Malpelo off of Costa Rica and Columbia.
That might be it. Those two places. Only two
places I can think of on the planet where
you can still see this. [pause]
There are other things in Galapagos underwater.
There’s a healthy turtle population. This
is a green turtle at a dive site called Cousins’
Rock. Of course, there are whale sharks too.
This is one of the best places to photograph
whale sharks. Very large whale sharks, mostly
female. I’ve only ever seen one male whale
shark in Galapagos.
This was one of the only really friendly ones
I’ve ever seen there, who just hung out.
I mean, all of those divers on the surface
are out of air. What we’re doing is trying
to snorkel around this whale shark who’s
just hanging out and rubbing up against boats,
doing weird things.
The other thing is: this whale shark would
pick one diver and swim towards it until you
got out of the way or it forced you out of
the way. [laughter] This is our dive guide,
who just couldn’t get out of the way fast
enough. They’re harmless. They—
>>Male #1: Is he snorkeling? Is he actually
snorkeling?
>>Cheng: I don’t know if he has a snorkel
on, but he’s out of air. So he’s in dive
gear, but on the surface. Yeah.
So these sharks are the biggest fish in the
ocean. They can get up to around 40 feet long.
They are totally harmless. They’re plankton
eaters. Amazing fish to see. [pause]
Some more sharks. This is a lemon shark. It
is—This was taken in the Bahamas. We call
this sort of shot a “lemon snap.” It’s
taken at a very, very close range. That water
line is on my camera. So the water line is
on the dome port of the camera, and the shark
is a couple inches away.
The Bahamas are one of the best places to
photograph sharks, big sharks. This is the
boat that I’ve been going on a lot. It’s
called the Shearwater. It goes out of Palm
Beach. It’s four hours overnight to this
area of the Bahamas.
The trips that I run are very camera-heavy,
of course. We have serious photographers coming
along, and we typically have a dozen high-end,
very large cameras on these trips.
In the lower left you can see the population
of lemon sharks. It’s very healthy there.
What we do is sit on this swim step here and
put our cameras in the water. Then we use
hookless lines with a little bit of fish to
attract them to the boat. They don’t do this
anymore, unfortunately, so if you want to
do this, you can now go and use a pole cam.
This was in the early days when things were
a little more free. [laughs]
So you can see some shots of how we’re getting
these shots. That’s me in the upper right
hand corner there with the shark coming in.
[pause]
There are also tiger sharks there. It’s a
really great place to photograph tiger sharks.
I’ll show some pictures of those in a minute.
Here are shots of a tiger shark coming in
on some fish. Again, we use no hooks here,
so there’s no chance of hurting the sharks.
[pause]
So for those lemon snaps, that mouth open-close
motion can last a fraction of a second. It
can be very difficult to capture. The trick,
really, is to take a lot of pictures, and
not to—certainly not to retreat, because
the camera is the thing between you and the
shark. If you’re not there, they can sometimes
swim on the swim step, which is really uncomfortable
for those people around you who have not moved
yet. [laughs] Or I was yelling, “Hold the
line! Hold the line!” because you have to
make sure that you have a solid line of cameras
there. [laughter] Yeah.
Also, we use both acrylic and glass stone
ports underwater. Acrylic is—has the same—a
very similar index of refraction as water
does, so it’s more invisible in the water,
but it scratches very easily. Shark skin will
scratch an acrylic dome port. If a shark brushes
by your port, it basically goes opaque, and
then you have to polish it off. Glass doesn’t
really have that problem, but if you have
a dam—if you damage your glass dome port,
it’s not possible, really, to fix it. Certainly
not in the field. [pause]
So here’s one of my favorite lemon snapshots.
And I’ll show you a few more. It makes them
look pretty vicious, and so I’m a little
bit torn about sharing these pictures, because
I don’t want to portray them as being vicious.
But I love that they have teeth, and they’re
these amazing predators. So it’s always that—It’s
always trying to walk that fine line in terms
of balance. Pretty much, if you see a shark
with small, pointy teeth, it’s not dangerous.
Small, pointy teeth means they eat fish. You’re
not on their prey list. If they bite you,
it’s probably because of something you did.
[pause] [laughter]
>>Male #4: They’re swallowing.
>>Cheng: [laughs] So these are—These sharks
are five to seven feet long. Maybe some eight
footers. They’re not very big. [pause] This
is that moment that they snap their jaws shut.
And some stuff shot later in the day. This
is pretty close to nighttime.
>>Cheng: We are baiting them using fishing
lines with no hooks. We tie a little piece
of fish on. You can see a little bit of water
coming off of the piece of fish on the top
of this frame. Baiting can be a controversial
issue for sharks.
>>Male #5: Are these second curtain sync or
something? That looks like a couple different
exposures.
>>Cheng: A second curtain sync? Yeah. These
shots are second curtain sync, yeah. But shot
at the max sync speed. So 1/200 or 1/250.
Yeah. Baiting can be controversial. Many conservationists
do not like baiting sharks in. But I think,
really, the two options are: don’t bait sharks,
which means you don’t get any pictures of
sharks, or video, so you can’t share how
amazing they are to people, and they get killed.
That’s basically how I see it. That’s on
the one side. The other side is: do a little
bit of baiting. Have areas that are very carefully
managed for tourism where people pay. Sharks
are worth much more alive than they are dead.
That has been shown in many, many reports.
Tourism brings in much more money than killing
one shark. [pause]
Okay, here’s another—this is another shot
that is a little bit unusual. It’s the eye
of a tiger shark. I’ve spent a ton of time
in the Bahamas photographing tiger sharks.
In the Bahamas, we have very clear water when
we’re in with these tiger sharks. It’s very
shallow, and they move very slowly in these
situations. There’s not these—It’s not
a place where tiger sharks are ambushing marine
mammals, so they’re probably more scavengers
here than they are ambush predators. So we
really do find that they move very slowly.
You have to be careful, of course, because
they are wild animals. But as you can see,
you can get very close. They are so fixated
on finding out where that fish smell is that
they just swim around you looking for the
stuff.
We do know many of these tiger sharks individually
by name. We’ve been photographing some of
them for eight years or so. Some individuals.
They’re pretty friendly. This is one of the
on the bottom. She’s probably one of those
famous tiger sharks. She’s named Emma. She
has a Facebook page. [laughter] Maybe a Google+
page, even.
So this is the best place to photograph tiger
sharks. You have lots of opportunity. I’ve
had up to ten around me at a time. Other people
have had 25 show up.
>>Male #6: Is that a shipwreck or something
on the upper left?
>>Cheng: The question’s about the photo on
the upper left. It is a shipwreck. It’s called
Sugar Wreck, a very shallow shipwreck full
of life, so it’s a great place to dive or
snorkel. Although I wouldn’t recommend snorkeling
when tiger sharks are around, which we’ve
had happen before.
>>Male #1: Why? What’s the difference between
snorkeling and diving?
>>Cheng: The difference is you’re on the
surface, and sharks pretty much always investigate
anything floating on the surface. So if you
want to get attention from a shark, just jump
in and float around, and you’ll get—[laughter]
There will be—And there are sharks around.
They’ll investigate you. They’re not necessarily
going to just attack you, but what they will
do is bump you a lot. They’re very, very
careful. And eventually, they might take a
test bite if you don’t react. So you do have
to be very aware in these situations. You
have to always face the shark and react. I
mean, I found many times that the sharks almost
always approach from behind. If you turn around
a look at a shark, there’s a good chance
it’ll turn away. They’re very in tune to
where you’re looking.
>>Male #1: There’s a chance of ?
[laughter]
>>Cheng: Good chance. Well, no. I’ve tried
pretty hard down there. [laughs] I’ve escaped
without ever having contact. Of course, I
have a large camera between me and the animals.
I decided I wanted to get some different shots,
shake things up a little bit. So we have done
some night dives with these sharks as well.
You can get a nice black background. Then
what I did was I put a macro lens on.
That shot in the lower right is how you feel
when you look at the shark. Most shark pictures
are shot super wide angle or fisheye, and
so you get this looooong serpentine look to
the shark. That is not what they look like.
This shot really shows the girth of these
animals. And then as they get closer, you
can start to focus on detail. Some gill detail,
eye detail. This shot is an uncropped shot
of the eye. If you zoom in a little bit, you
can see the shape of the pupil, even, this
baseball diamond-like shape. [pause]
People feel like tiger sharks-- like they
communicate more because their eyes are less—they’re
a little bit more like ours. If you look at
a lemon shark eye, it looks very feline. It
looks alien.
Okay, another unusual shot. [laughter] Pigs!
>>Male #7: I’ve never seen one of those.
>>Cheng: Yeah. Domestic pigs that have gone
feral. These are also shot in the Bahamas.
These pictures were taken during a trip to
look for oceanic white tip sharks. White tips,
which are starting to make the way back in
the ocean. They were almost completely fished
out. In the Bahamas, in the tongue of the
ocean, in the middle where it’s really deep,
there’s a population now growing of these
oceanic white tips. There’s an island there
called Big Major Cay, which has these pigs
living on the beach with babies. So little
piglets there occasionally. The locals feed
them, so they’ll come in and feed them scraps.
What the pigs are doing now is swimming out
to the boats that are coming in. And so we
just take cameras in the water and it’s a
lot of fun. [pause]
Here’s some behind-the-scenes shots. They’re
actually—they’re pretty big, and they’re
focused. A couple of my friends there put
peanut butter on their cameras. [laughter]
That really draws the pigs in. Yeah. They
can, in fact, swim over you. It hurts. [laughs]
[laughter]
So this might be the most fun you can have
with a pig, legally. [loud laughter] These
are—[laughs] These are some shots on the
way to taking this shot, which is one of my
favorite portraits. And, of course, there
are people in it, so I had to crop them out.
>>Male #1: What’s the trick to the split
shot?
>>Cheng: What’s the trick to the split shot?
The trick is to use a large dome port. The
more surface area you have, the less chop
in the water will affect the shot. It’s also
to—Depending on the material and how old
the dome port is, water will sheet differently.
These shots were almost all taken with water
completely covering the dome port. I dipped
the dome in the water, and I pulled it out
of the water. Before it beads, I take a picture.
Some people have managed to figure out ways
with their dome ports to make it completely—
>>Male #1:
>>Cheng: The coating is—People use spit,
and they use baby shampoo sometimes. I’ve
seen  attempted, which does not
work because it beads most of the water off,
but then it leaves lots of little beads, which
show up. I find that the way I’ve been most
successful is by using clean glass dome ports
that have not been etched by diesel. Diesel
will etch these dome ports if you leave them
in the bottom of the tender of a boat. The
water in there has some gas and some fuel
in it. That, I found, has been pretty disruptive
to glass. There are a lot of tricks.
>>Male #8: Why not acrylic?
>>Cheng: Why not acrylic? I just haven’t
had as much luck with acrylic. I feel like
it doesn’t sheet as well for some reason.
I’m not sure why. Maybe a brand new acrylic
port that’s super smooth could do it. You
can get them with both. The best way is just
to keep it dry. Keep the top half dry if you
can. If it’s totally smooth water, you can
dry it off and then be very careful about
your shot. But very often, we’re floating,
and just come up from a dive, and you’re
shooting a split. So you have to work with
what you have. [pause] [man coughs]
This is another whale shark, another split
of a whale shark shot. This is a whale shark
feeding. It’s in Isla Mujeres in the Gulf
of Mexico, just off the Yucatán. This is
happening right now. In fact, Wetpixel has
a trip running right now. Yesterday, they
reported between three and four hundred whale
sharks on the surface. What’s happening here—And
this town, by the way, is fantastic. If you
hate Cancun, you will love Isla Mujeres. [laughter]
>>Male #1: What is it called again?
>>Cheng: Isla Mujeres. This is a place. It’s
a little island off of Cancun that feels still
very local. This is the touristy strip, so
it’s not that bad, and even in the tourist
strip. But if you go a couple blocks of, it
still feels very local. Everybody drives golf
carts around. There are a lot of tourists
on the island, but it’s a nice feel.
But what’s great is it’s very close to this
whale shark aggregation every summer. On permit,
these boats go out and look for these whale
sharks that are feeding out there. This is
a shot. Each one of those fins is a whale
shark.
The average length of a whale shark here,
according to some of the scientists there,
is about 7 meters. So 24 feet, something like
that. There are, of course, some that are
much larger, and a few that are much smaller.
But this is the largest known concentration
of the largest fish on the planet. [pause]
It’s really an incredible place. This were
taken from the tuna tower of the boat. If
you get lower, you can shoot multiple shark
fins in one shot. But really, it’s great
for underwater photography. Of course, you
have unlimited opportunity to take pictures
of whale sharks here. Every minute or two,
a whale shark will just swim by you. If you’re
not paying attention, it might even hit you.
It’s pretty incredible.
And these sorts of silhouette shots are done
by free diving down and then swimming so the
shark is between you and the sun. There’s
the added bonus that this one’s pooping [laughter]
which always makes for a better shot.
>>Male #9: So you said Wetpixel runs this
trip every year?
>>Cheng: We run this trip—Wetpixel runs this
trip every year. There are some other organizations
that do as well. If you’re more casual about
how you want to approach it, you can just
go to Isla Mujeres and get on a tourist boat,
which would give you half an hour on the water,
or so. Yeah. It’s not as good for photography,
but it’s a great experience and it’s much
cheaper.
>>Male #1: Why did you say “free diving”?
>>Cheng: Free diving. You’re not allowed
to scuba dive here, so it is—And really,
if you’re diving, you can’t swim. If you
have all that gear on, it’s very hard to
swim. So it’s a much better experience by
snorkel and free dive.
These are shots of whale sharks feeding. These
were taken of sharks when they—They’re called
“botellas”, like a bottle. They float like
this: vertical with their mouths open on the
top, and just gulp in all the plankton they
can. They just spin slowly. If you’re very
careful, you can get close and shoot right
down their mouths here. [pause]
This is what they’re after. These are tiny
eggs, or little bonito-like tuna. These guys
are spawning there at every full moon. So
the sharks are in the area waiting, and when
it happens, they aggregate in groups of hundreds.
And hundreds are what you count on the surface,
so it may be that there are many more. [pause]
Yeah, it’s great. You have—We have six hours
a day to take pictures of these sharks. You
can get pretty creative. [pause]
There is a random picture in here. Oh, it
went away. Okay. Here, this is a video of
[pause] [video starts playing] of me swimming
around. [jaunty video music playing] [video
stops playing] So that gives you an idea of
how many there are. This was shot in one take.
Eleven whale sharks went by. [pause]
Okay. This is another shot. I call this one
“interspecies encounter.” This is actually
in the talk that Ricardo embedded on the Google
Events. So if you want more information about
this shot and this area, you can go check
that out. But this was taken off of Dominica
in the Caribbean. It’s a place known for
its sperm whale population. There are a couple
pods of sperm whales off the coast here, which
are all very well studied by scientists. They
know each of the whales individually. Photographers
can get permits, as well, to get in the water
with them there. Marine mammals are pretty
well protected, so if you want to get in the
water with a whale, you have to be on permit.
We use hydrophones to find these whales. Sperm
whales make a lot of noise. They click. They
have, in fact, a coda for just certain populations,
so you can tell which population of whales
from by the pattern that they use to greet
each other. They use very loud noises at depth,
1000 meters down when they feed. They have
specific feeding noises, and so you can track
them as they move around on their dives, which
are typically 45-50 minutes long. Then when
they come up, hopefully you’re in the right
place.
We got really lucky there. There were a lot
of sperm whales socializing. These sperm whales
were rubbing up against each other. They’re
rubbing dead skin off of each other. It was
really spectacular to be able to get up so
close to them.
I think they’re the largest carnivore on
the planet? In theory, the males can get up
to around 60 feet long. They have teeth. These
are mostly juvenile males and females of all
ages. Again, because they were so—They just
basically ignored us here. You could take
some more interesting shots instead of just
going for whatever shot you can get. So I
shot splits, these vertical splits, and then
I dove down to their heads to try to get shots
of them hanging in the water upside down.
This is also on snorkel, on free dive. [pause]
More shots here. The one on the left is--
That little piece there, of red, is actually
part of a squid arm, which is what they feed
on. This one in the middle is a juvenile about
to do a tail slap on the surface. You’ve
seen—If you go whale watching, you’ll see
tails come out of the water and slap. That’s
what it looks like underwater.
And then this one on the right may be nursing,
although that’s unconfirmed. And I don’t
think anyone knows how sperm whales nurse.
It could be like this. Who knows? [sighs]
If only marine mammals researchers worked
with photographers.
Now, this whale is named Scar. He was—this
is maybe three years ago-- at the time around
ten years old, and was the friendliest of
the bunch. He’s been interacting with humans
for his entire life. This whale would literally
just come in and get right in front of you.
In fact, you could swim in—You had to swim
away from this whale to get a picture of it.
[light laughter]
This is the guide who knows Scar the best.
I would never advocate swimming up to a whale
and touching it, but this whale, Scar, actually
closed his eyes. You can see his eyes there
that are closed. And then all of us went in
and just rubbed him down. It was—We couldn’t
resist, really. [pause] Pretty incredible
encounter.
>>Male #1: One of your G+ posts said that
he disappeared last year.
>>Cheng: The question is about whether he’s
still there or not. I have not seen any recent
pictures of Scar. They do leave—Males leave
the area where they grew up when they get
to a certain age, and they go to the polar
regions to then hunt and eat until they’re
much larger and they come back to breed, to
mate. I’m not sure whether he’s still there.
People are still going there, because it’s
still a really great place to get—a lot of
film crews are there to get footage of sperm
whales. But I’m not sure if he’s still there.
[pause]
I like this shot because it just shows that
moment of connection between whale and human.
I have a little bit of video of the sperm
whales, as well. This was taken with a Canon
5D Mark II. [video starts playing] [water
sounds] One of the great things about the
cameras now is that you can instantly start
shooting video if you see something that is
better captured that way. [video continues
playing] [tapping and clicking sounds] This
is natural light. They’re really too big
to light up with strobes. [video continues
playing] All these sounds are from the whales,
and that tapping, that pattern, that pattern
is the pattern that this group uses. [video
continues playing]
>>Male #10: How easy is it to control the
camera?
>>Cheng: It’s really easy to turn it on.
It’s hard to ensure that you’re in focus.
We pretty much prefocus these. They’re shot
so wide, I’ll focus on my fin [video stops
playing] and just stop down. But they’re
also hard to hold steady. Dedicated video
cameras are designed to be held steady, and
the housings have a lot of mass, so it’s
hard to shake them. But an SLR housing has
two handles on the side, so if you just move
a little bit, it shakes. It takes a lot of
practice to shoot smoothly. I think it’s
impossible to have a shot that looks like
it was completely smooth with an SLR.
I think that’s all the pictures I have to
show today. I do have-- This portfolio link
goes to my Google+ page where there are 300
pictures uploaded. And, of course, Wetpixel
is a site for those of you who are interested
in underwater photography. I think we have
time for some questions. Do we? Yeah.
>>Male #11: Do you do any diving in Monterey?
>>Cheng: Do I do any diving in Monterey? I
do some diving in Monterey, but not as much
as I’d like to. I’ve actually done more
diving in Alaska than I have in Monterey.
But it’s right here, and it’s incredible.
It’s some of the best cold water diving in
the world. In fact, this weekend, there’s
a big shootout in Monterey, where people go
and compete in a photo contest. There is a
film festival where I’ll be speaking as well.
Yeah. Other questions?
>>Male #12: I want to know about the radio
triggers for the flash.
>>Cheng: Radio triggers for the flash? We
don’t use radio triggers. We use either electrical
sync cords or optical sync. You have to trigger
the camera somehow. For a while, when digital
cameras came out, underwater photographers
lost the ability to use TTL, because every—That
went D-TTL and i-TTL, and Canon went E-TTL.
And none of the underwater strobe manufacturers
could catch up. So we shot—And that’s when
I started shooting. So we pretty much shot
manual. Everything was manual.
But I find, in general, all you need is a
signal to fire the strobe, because if you
rely on TTL, especially for macro, and you
have more than one strobe, the pictures end
up looking really flat. The idea is to think
about shadows. Shadows are the most important
thing for underwater macrophotography. You
always want to think about where that shadow’s
going to be cast. Since so many animals underwater
are totally camouflaged, the best way to cut
them out of the environment is to make them
cast a shadow on their host.
>>Male #13: So you’re—
>>Cheng: Oh, go ahead.
>>Male #13: What do you think is your most
dangerous encounter ever? Anything you’ve
ever been close to?
>>Cheng: [laughs] My most dangerous encounter
ever? I don’t think my most dangerous encounters
have been wildlife related. [laughter] It’s
mostly been in a situation where you’re in
a very high current environment and you’ve
pushed yourself somehow. I’m too deep, I’m
in deco, I don’t have much air left, and
all I can see are my bubbles streaming off
into the blue when I’m ready to let go to
go do a safety stop where you drift for three
to five minutes, plus deco time. So there
have been some moments like that that are
very visceral memories where I’m—my back
is to the current, and I’m just staring at
my bubbles going down, and thinking, “Okay,
this is going to be—I hope the boat follows
me.”
So there were some moments like that. Luckily,
I’ve never had anything truly life-threatening.
I think most of my friends who have been doing
this for a long time have been bent or have
had some kind of serious malfunction. Their
first stage blows off their tank or something
really disastrous. The only real—The only
lethal incidents, at least, amongst my friends,
have involved rebreathers. They have a rebreather
accident and they die. Or the occasional surf
photographer can get smashed in the coral.
So there are just a few—Sometimes, there
are really unfortunate events, especially
rebreather stuff. Even really experienced
rebreather divers can have accidents like
that. It’s less forgiving than open circuit.
[pause]
Other questions?
>>Male #1: So have you done much rebreather
diving at all?
>>Cheng: I’ve done some rebreather diving.
I don’t own one, but I typically will dive
it in Papua New Guinea where there’s a boat
that I go on that has them.
>>Male #1: Why is that? Why only there?
>>Cheng: It’s mostly that I just don’t own
one. I haven’t invested in one.
>>Male #1: And you think they’re dangerous.
>>Cheng: Well, I think if you don’t use them
a lot, if you’re not very comfortable with
them, they can be dangerous. I love them.
I mean, rebreathers, for those of you who
don’t know, are fully closed circuits, so
they scrub the CO2 out of what you exhale,
and inject a very small amount of oxygen into
the system. It’s bubble-free. Almost everything
underwater is afraid of bubbles. If you ever
go underwater and hold your breath or are
on a rebreather, divers make a ton of noise.
You can hear divers long before you can see
them, in the water. It affects the wildlife.
You can immediately see the fish start hiding.
With every exhalation, if you have someone
on scuba who’s taking video, you can watch
the fish pulse in and out as they breathe.
With a rebreather, you just don’t see that.
And the other benefit of using a rebreather
for photography and videography is that as
you breathe, your buoyancy does not change,
because there’s a counterlung. You exhale
into the counterlung, so the amount of air
stays constant. With open circuit, every time
you inhale, you start to float, and every
time you exhale, you start to sink. That makes
it really hard to hold a camera steady. So
rebreathers—Most serious videographers will
shoot on a rebreather. [pause]
>>Female #2: You talked a little bit about
sharks. I was wondering if you’re doing anything
in terms of awareness to the concentration
of those sharks?
>>Cheng: The question’s about awareness and
conservation around sharks. I work really
closely with an organization called Shark
Savers, which is a conservation organization
dedicated to policy and awareness around shark
finning and how unsustainable it is. Most
of the direct action happens in the Chinese-speaking
world, so mostly Hong Kong, China, Taiwan.
But a lot of the fundraising happens here.
So yeah, I think most people are afraid of
sharks. There’s that fallout from Jaws, and
a lot of the media we see. Shark Week is coming
up. Shark Week is usually 90 or 95% sensationalist
stuff about sharks. “Top 10 Most Dangerous
Sharks”, that kind of thing. We’re working
directly with them to try to influence programming
as well, and to see how much we can get them
to publish real facts around sharks. I mean,
there’s an average of five people killed
a year by sharks, but you hear about every
one of those, maybe more than once. It feels
like people are being killed by sharks all
the time, but in fact, you’re probably more
likely to die from just about anything else.
>>Female #2: Are you making any
policy?
>>Cheng: I’m not directly involved in a lot
of the—in the policy stuff, but what we noticed
in the last few years is that a lot of countries
and states are now banning shark fins. California
banned shark fin. This is the last year. You
can’t buy it anymore if you own a restaurant,
but you can still serve it this year. We’re
finding a lot of legislation, now, to ban
shark fins. But mostly, it has to happen in
Asian, high-density Asian areas, so mostly
in Asia.
And it’s already starting. The Chinese government
said they won’t serve it anymore at official
government events. A lot of celebrities in
Hong Kong, Taiwan, China are now speaking
out against it. It’s really an education
thing. When most people learn about what’s
involved in making a bowl of shark fin, which
is basically finning a shark and throwing
away the body and keeping the fin, because
it’s so much more valuable, they—especially
the younger generation—is very much against
it. So hopefully, people will have their minds
changed before sharks are gone. [pause]
Questions?
>>Male #14: Are animals sensitive to light?
>>Cheng: Are animals sensitive to light?
>>Male #14: Yeah, are they scared by light?
>>Cheng: Yeah. Most animals are affected by
light in some way. This is all, again, highly
controversial as well, because, I mean, if
you image a giant strobe flashing in your
face if you’re a pygmy seahorse, it could
be very distracting. [laughs] But having said
that, I’ve seen pygmy seahorses feeding while
they’re being photographed, so sometimes
they’re not affected. I think they’re—most
things will just run from things that are
not—that are scary. They’ll typically try
to get away from you, just as a diver, regardless
of your lights. But sometimes, you get one
shot, and that first strobe flash will make
the animal run.
We do use red lights a lot at night. We find
that many animals are less sensitive to red
light, presumably because there’s no red
light down there. So any animal that’s red
is probably trying to hide, because there’s
no red light. [pause]
Questions?
>>Female #3: Do you shoot more landscapes,
like not animals stuff?
>>Cheng: Do I shoot landscapes underwater,
or—
>>Female #3: Yes, or ?
>>Cheng: Oh, okay. Yeah, I shoot a lot of
reefscapes, reef scenes that are colorful
and show that there’s a lot of life in the
water. And the occasional interesting topography,
like crevices and a little bit of cave stuff.
Wrecks are really artificial reefs these days.
If you sink a ship and leave it for any amount
of time, it will collect a huge amount of
wildlife around it. Some people are interested
in the wrecks for historical context, and
they want to go find the bell or swim through
the grand ballroom, but I really like wrecks
because they collect a lot of wildlife. In
some wrecks, in fact, you can’t see the wreck.
It is completely covered in coral and fish.
>>Female #3: Do you have to be super far away?
>>Cheng: You have to be super far away to
photograph and entire wreck, yes, typically.
And there are some photographers who specialize
in that. They’ll go down 300 feet with a
heavy tripod and plant themselves in front
of a giant wreck, taking long exposure stuff
in the dim light. And then they’ll decompress
over hours going back to the surface.
>>Male #15: Have there been any species that
have been particularly elusive for you to
photograph?
>>Cheng: Species that have been elusive? Yeah,
certainly. We went looking for sperm whales
in Japan, and we had—One of my friends and
I were the first to photograph sperm whales
eating giant squid. But the giant squid is
the classic elusive animal that no one’s
really photographed. There’s a little bit
of video on the surface of one alive, and
that’s it. I would say that as a scuba diver,
it’s not realistic to think that I would
ever see a giant squid alive, because they
live at 1000 meters. Yeah.
But there are a lot of animals I’d like to
see. I’d love to do a Humboldt squid. They’re
a five to seven foot squid on the California
coast near Mexico into Baja California. And
there’re just schools of squid that can be—that
flash, and they’re really cool.
Are we done?
>>Presenter: We’re done. We’re out of time.
>>Cheng: [laughs] All right. Okay, thanks.
>>Presenter: Thanks, Eric, for coming to Google.
[applause]